love for the story honestly it has to
just be something that you believe in
that you want to tell because you're
going to be living with it for a very
long time and there are many obstacles
whether financial or personal or I mean
there's so many obstacles with
documentary filmmaking that I think it
had there has to be a deep love for for
that subject matter in order to really
propel you through I think with children
in the ground I was actually right out
of graduate school and I was actually
interviewing for jobs and I had to pitch
story ideas and then I came across an
article about prostitution among street
children in various countries and I
started doing more research into it and
I realized that my god this is I don't I
don't want to pitch this for a 10 minute
you know news piece or Enterprise piece
I wanted to do a long-form documentary
on it and so at that point I really
started fundraising through grants or
into finding individuals who were
interested in that subject matter but
with children underground I think it was
my god in the beginning I was temping
for a while I was doing it and finding
all sorts of ways to make ends meet
until I i received a grant from the the
source foundation and that was really
what enabled me to make the film and
support myself at the live at the same
time and then once i received that then
then more funding came in but i think
it's um it's doing what you need to do
in order to make to start and then once
you start and you build momentum then
people start getting involved and you
figure out a way I think to do and find
certain foundations and people who are
interested in it but with my first film
without the support of I mean and I had
applied to you know dozens probably you
know close to a hundred different
foundations and before I actually
received that one grant would
abled me to make the film I think if you
focus on I think you need to stay true
to your subject matter and stay true to
the filaments and in and stay true to
your story and your vision and if you
start thinking about the money it's
going to make and and how then I think
that it's a different it's a different
beast entirely and I think that the most
important thing is is is is telling the
story in in the truest way and and and
keeping your focus in that way and not
thinking about thinking about how much
money is going to make in the box office
box office I mean that has a place as
well and you know for certain films um
but I think even i think that the focus
has to be on on the storytelling and
your objective because you're with the
films that I'm dealing with you're
dealing with people's lives and it's
completely different I think for me
that's putting the cart before the horse
I mean I think the focus for a young
filmmaker it's really just following the
story that you feel is so important to
tell what and you feel passionately
about that and I think that has to be
the first thing once you lose that then
then I think that you are a part of the
millions you were just trying to get
something out there but I think people
respond to to to honesty and and 2 to
the filmmakers passion you know and I
think that comes through the
storytelling and so I think that that
has to come first i think that if you
put that first then everything else will
follow and then you'll figure out a way
down to get it out there and people will
respond to to what you've done but it's
difficult for me to actually think of it
that one